sie verliebten sich im grundschulalter
wurden dann aber recht schnell
unfreiwillig getrennt 37 jahre später
trifft sich das pärchen wieder und die
liebe ist kein tag gealtert
nach 37 jahren sind sie endlich wieder
vereint
elke und jörg teilen beide eine traurige
vergangenheit als kinder lernen sich die
beiden weimarer in einem kinderheim
kennen schnell wissen sie es ist lieber
gewohnt gleich groß ungefähr und wussten
sofort los hat dieselben interessen
haben uns gesehen und das war wie
bestimmungen auf den ersten heimlichen
kurs im alter von sieben jahren folgt
die hochzeit mit gänseblümchen ring
doch leider hält das glück der beiden
nicht länger sie werden von der
heimleitung getrennt und sehen sich
ganze 37 jahre nicht wieder
ich bin früh auf dem schulweg und habe
ich noch den erzieher gefragt wo slk ist
weg da hab ich doch die ist normal heute
weg oder irgendwie hat man nichts weiter
dabei gedacht irgendwann habe ich
festgestellt die kommt gar nicht wieder
ecke kann ihren york aber nie so ganz
vergessen und macht sich im
erwachsenenalter noch einmal auf die
suche nach ihrer ersten großen liebe
dann bekam ich erst mal eine e mail da
stand drin
ich bin älter habe ich dort gut welche
ecke es gab in unserer klasse mehrere
die lg gießen ja es stimmt ich habe es
insgeheim gehofft
so habe ich noch gedacht auch mensch
hätte doch mal die telefonnummer dazu
geschrieben
zwei minuten später ging es wieder sie
haben post stand die telefonnummer dabei
dann habe ich natürlich gleich allen mut
zusammengenommen und dann aber
telefoniert ich glaube vier stunden am
erfurter hauptbahnhof treffen sich die
beiden nach fast vier jahrzehnten das
erste mal wieder und die alte liebe
entbrennt aufs neue und in dem mit wiese
die tender angefasst habe 15
schmetterlinge wir sind immer noch
verliebt wie am ersten tag ja das ist
ich habe immer noch die schmetterlinge
im bauch am 10 juli 2014 genau zwei
jahre nach ihrem wiedersehen heiraten
jörg und elke ganz offiziell
diesmal mit goldenem und keinem
gänseblümchen ring
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren